in the streets around Scotland Yard the
man who'd reveled in his nickname Yates
of the yard seem so determined to battle
on sideswiping growing calls for his
resignation but such is the frantic
piece of this ever deepening crisis
within hours the Mets assistant
commissioner decided to follow his boss
and fall on his sword it is a matter of
great personal regret that those
potentially affected by phone hacking
were not dealt with appropriately sadly
there continues to be a huge amount of
inaccurate ill-informed and on occasions
downright malicious gossip being
published about me personally I have
acted with complete integrity and my
conscience is clear it's hard to
overstate the seriousness of the crisis
now engulfing the country's biggest
police force allegations of a botched
phone hacking investigation and even
corruption of cost two of its most
senior officers their jobs earlier
members of the metropolitan police
authorities professional standards
committee had decided there was enough
evidence to suspend Assistant
Commissioner gates but now he's decided
to go attention is turning increasingly
towards the political first the London
Mayor a man who famously branded those
fresh hacking allegations as codswallop
yet to go on the advice he'll given by
senior police officers and advice I was
getting was that there was was it was
nothing you and you can see the
consequences of that bad advice today
pretty obvious in it but in question
after question the Mayor was left
verbally battered and bruised and that's
why we're having this investigation yes
Bureau after the mirrored was deterrent
at the Home Secretary to face the heat
assurances of new more transparent
procedures of the Met did nothing to
temper her critics in the Commons the
judgment of the men
have been called into serious question
by appointing Neil Wallace but so has
the judgment of the prime minister by
appointing new Wallace's boss andy
coulson people will look at this and
think it is one rule for the police and
one for the Prime Minister so Assistant
Commissioner John Yates has now gone but
absolutely no one believes he'll be the
last casualty of the phone hacking
crisis